en términos reales que puede salir de
este encuentro Si vemos por ejemplo que
para sentarse a negociar maduro exige
descongelamiento de dineros y
levantamiento de sanciones y Estados
Unidos acondicionado esto a que se
celebren las elecciones libres
Gracias Valentina y Bueno creo que es
una oportunidad importante para informar
que el día de ayer más de 200
organizaciones la sociedad civil
venezolana e internacional y también
voces ciudadanas nos unimos a un
comunicado justamente donde expresábamos
a los países que son parte de esta
conferencia internacional sobre
Venezuela la importancia de que se diera
un compromiso con la
reinstitucionalización democrática en el
país y especialmente una acción
multilateral coordinada por la paz por
los derechos humanos y por la justicia
para nosotros vemos con buenos ojos y de
forma positiva justamente que hayan
estos esfuerzos diplomáticos que se
generen estos acuerdos o escenarios de
encuentro para hablar sobre la crisis
multidimensional que vive Venezuela y es
necesario y es central que estos
acuerdos que estas discusiones tengan
como Norte Como base y en el centro la
garantía y el respeto de los Derechos
Humanos esa aproximación de Derechos
Humanos es justamente lo que va a
permitir que esta conferencia y que
cualquier acuerdo o cualquier
conversación que tenga se tenga sobre
Venezuela tenga futuro justamente Dentro
de este comunicado que hicimos hacíamos
planteamientos de cómo se debe entender
Esta aproximación es sobre Derechos
Humanos y sobre todo planteamos la
importancia de la no impunidad el tema
de justicia en Venezuela es fundamental
y el tema de garantía protección
investigación sobre el tema de Derechos
Humanos es central Más allá del tema
migratorio que motiva a Petro a convocar
esta conferencia si ya ha dicho que no
se considera un mediador
Bueno yo creo que Venezuela y la crisis
venezolana necesita de la solidaridad
internacional de de justamente un
liderazgo regional que se comprometa no
a corto plazo no con iniciativas
puntuales sino justamente que desarrolle
un compromiso un liderazgo comprometido
a largo plazo Porque además la crisis
Venezuela es una crisis de larga Data de
diferentes dimensiones que requiere una
solidaridad de un apoyo regional
internacional y que vemos positivo estos
esfuerzos que que están se están
generando desde Colombia pero
necesitamos que sean Genuinos y esta y
esta estos en unidad de estos esfuerzos
requieren el centro en derechos humanos
donde haya un reconocimiento de la
emergencia humanitaria donde Hoy hay
personas en necesidad humanitaria en
Venezuela y fuera de Venezuela crisis de
la movilidad humana Colombia es testigo
de eso donde requerimos un proceso de
paz que incluya las organizaciones la
sociedad civil pero que también nos
proteja como actores en esta
construcción y transformación del
conflicto donde entiendan las elecciones
como una clave principal en un proceso
en este proceso de remolentización que
vamos a tener elecciones en momentos
electorales en el 2024 y 2025 que
también se entienda el tema de la
justicia como un tema central teníamos
la publicación del informe de la sección
de víctimas recientemente donde se dan
las dimensiones de la afectación a la
justicia a las violaciones graves a los
Derechos Humanos a los crímenes atroces
que se han cometido en el país y como
cualquier acuerda cualquier conversación
debe tener estos puntos centrados es
decir la las aristas económicas son
importantes pero el el las dimensiones
de la problemática de Venezuela deben
tener la base los derechos humanos y
debe haber un compromiso no solamente de
Petro sino de cualquiera de los países
latinoamericanos europeos que están
participando en la democracia y re
democratización de Venezuela le pregunto
brevemente con el panorama que vive
Venezuela actualmente las sanciones si
realmente tienen un efecto sobre el
gobierno de maduro
fíjate las sanciones se crearon
justamente porque hay violaciones a los
derechos humanos y a estas violaciones a
estas sanciones particulares y estas
sanciones generales desde las
organizaciones hemos planteado
justamente la afectación de las
sanciones generales pero las causas que
generaron la existencia de sanciones
siguen ahí en Venezuela se siguen
violando los derechos humanos en
Venezuela hay todavía responsables de
graves crímenes sobre la población que
no han sido ni investigados ni
sancionados y justamente se ha
evidenciado no hay voluntades
investigación no va a poder haber paz en
Venezuela no va a haber poder una
solución del conflicto sino lidiamos
justamente con las causas estructurales
pero especialmente allí el trabajo de la
misión determinación de los hechos dado
las recomendaciones dadas por los
organismos internacionales brindan esa
ruta para establecer la justicia atender
las violaciones de los Derechos Humanos
no solamente es un levantamiento de
sanciones es justamente atender la
respuesta y cumplir con todas esas
recomendaciones que se ha dado con los
bajo los organismos internacionales y
allí vamos a ver verdaderos indicaciones
de cambio indicadores de cambio y de
transformación en Venezuela